conan your murder for the last episode
was awesome just the same so was
marshawn's um how did that come about
and do you think that you would do more
stuff like that and do people approach
you to make appearances like that that's
that's a good question too uh
so i'll tell you exactly what happened
there i've
a lot of things i say no to because it
just doesn't feel right
um i get a call
and it's
i get a text it's will arnett he says i
can i get on the phone with you
and um i said sure so
he basically said
hey i'm doing this project
it's a really silly detective show
um and i'm always teamed with someone
who doesn't know what's happening it'll
be two days of shooting in the valley
and
will arnett is one of my favorite funny
people he didn't even finish the
sentence and i said yes
and then he did that thing where he was
like i mean uh i think it'd be really
good you know that's a great will our
next
[Laughter]
gmc trucks
um but because it was will
whenever i'm with him there's a couple
of people who if i'm with them all i do
is mess around we're never real with
each other yeah and it's will arnett
it's jack mcbrear whenever i'm with jack
i don't behave and and he goes into a
cat he
i become
the overbearing city guy yeah he's like
way way well you know look who just
stumbled out of the cornfield and he
goes like no sir i do not like it sir
he comes to my house every year for
christmas party we do that yeah you do
we stand next to the ham and i go like
wait
you probably don't know what these
electric lights are and he's like sir i
do know what electric lights are and
people are laughing
and occasionally someone thinks i'm
really doing that to him yeah i have
people occasionally like you should be
kind of nicer to jack mcfarland it's a
joke i'm doing my thing he's doing his
thing but that's the
relationship i have with will arnett so
he said let's do it and then it's quite
strange
uh you they don't tell you anything all
i knew was that i was a trainee
and
you're in your trailer they come in hair
makeup you're waiting you're waiting
you're waiting
then they bring you into this giant
warehouse
and
where they're shooting
and they bring you in the back and i
haven't even seen will yet i haven't
seen anybody and i'm behind a door
and they say when someone taps you go in
and i can just barely hear what they're
saying because i'm on the other side of
all this uh you know this set
and um
i'm quite a distance away and i just
hear you've got a new partner you know
not a new partner
well
here he is right now let's get him in
here and then someone just taps you on
the back and you walk in
and the next thing you know
um i haven't seen it yet myself but
people could tell me i keep saluting
people
and um i don't know what's happening
yeah and i just will say things and
will's trying to make me laugh and i'm
trying to make will laugh and
there are moments when you you broke you
know
we're just like having a really yeah he
kept you know and and um there are
little things like they bring this guy
in in cuffs and this magician and then
he's pulling all this stuff out and i'm
like don't people get searched when they
you know
and and wilt is this thing where he
laughs and holds his
so it then it's really fun but um
it's kind of like an escape room or
something like you don't know what's
happening it's a really good idea
i think for a show
and
i've had a lot of people say was the hot
sauce thing real yes it was really
real that was very hot hot sauce and
will kept putting more and more on and
my thing was i'm going to eat as much of
this as i can
and my eyes are watering and then
when the scene was over someone came
walking up to me everyone's masked and
everything but walking up to me with a
big plastic bucket
and said if you need to throw up
i'm like you were prepared for me to
throw up they didn't give you like milk
or anything they someone was standing
there with milk but i think they were
drinking it um
anyway it was really fun to do and yes
at this point if something sounds
like it could be
interesting
or different or fun i'm really up for it